tous ensemble bonjour la planète entière
qui est à l'écouté en ce moment où une
partie de l'ange un dixième de la
planète certains monter les côtes de
tonnes canada en direct de montréal
aujourd'hui
le congé est finie le congé de pâques
c'est fini oui donc on retrouve tout le
monde au travail
aujourd'hui on l'appelle en anglais le
dream team et en français ça se dit tout
aussi facilement
l'équipe de rêve que voici avec anne
marivin ça fait un mois qu'on vous
attendez pour le retour ça faisait deux
mois qu'elle s'était absentée paloma
martinez bonjour marie claude eux simard
de services web de radio-canada
international vocation parce qu'il ya
c'est son nom de famille qui me
dérangeait l'occasion 6 mars et ont
chassé comme ce n'est qu'à penser à un
chanteur populaire
rené simard merci beaucoup quelle belle
idée moi je pense pas que ce plus à
nathalie simard maintenant leonardo
gimeno de la section latino-américaine
bonjour on a besoin de webmestres et il
y en a que deux qui sont qualifiés pour
cette émission conduire spécial où il
dit voilà c'est les a laissés huit mois
cette cure 29 mois la gaffe à la capa
voici vous connaissez pas passer nouveau
il ya un nouveau jeu maintenant pourquoi
ah oui connaître le sujet des missions
on a la vidéo en cinq images top images
ça défile vous regardez les images comme
tout le monde du côté de l'internet et
vous ne dit qu'elle sera le sujet
aujourd'hui
dès que vous avez une idée vous vous
prononcez des arts 20 vous êtes sur la
piste vous pariez vous cacher des
enfants solitude c'est très bien très
bien très très bien servi
mais sur ce qu'on fait otis autistes
vous dites oui qu'est ce qui vous ferait
pas qu'une le regard plongé dans le vide
alors voilà la bonne réponse en arrivant
avec l'autre oui écrit ici en anglais je
pense à presque en fait j'ai un voisin
lourdement autistes en fait il a 22 ou
23 ans et il a de graves graves
problèmes mais évidemment il va être
dépendant de ses parents de sa famille
pour le restant de ses jours là oui
c'est cette formidable fantastique que
vous apportiez salle attane puisqu'on va
parler un spécialiste l'autisme on vous
pourrez comparer le batik et les
théories c'est poussé plusieurs niveaux
aussi je connais des enfants qui n'ont
pas beaucoup de problèmes
la commission scolaire marie claude dans
le journal du métro de montréal en fait
le magazine détenir un jour oui oui on a
eu la chance de vivre plusieurs bons
articles sur l'autize parce que c'est le
mois de l'autisme
alors écoutez vous êtes tant d'encre
dans le sujet est dans le coup 1 comme
on dit donc c'est un problème qui semble
assez commun voici la question pour le
premier jeu notre jeu de la grosse boule
premier tour
bon aujourd'hui pour 20 points voici la
question quel est le taux de prévalence
l'autisme ou du trouble du spectre de
l'autisme
il faut être plus exact de dire oui ça
c'est un petit canadien sur combien
maintenant il ya des troubles liés à
l'autisme qui sont des tic en
pourcentage 1 sur combien pourcentage si
vous voulez oui 10 10 712% 1 sur 5 1 sur
5 mois je connais la réponse des fans
j'ai lu ton article
je connais le chiffre précis
[Rires]
du porc au sein du pour ça alors ski que
c'est un enfant sur 66 alors qu'ils
pensent être le plus proche de bonnes
réponses en termes de pourcentage et pas
sur moi je suis pas bonne en maths la
main sur 66 a fait quoi
leonardo est la bonne réponse 2% gt2 pas
ça pour ça on est nuls maintenus oubliez
ça c'est pas gagné 20 points 20 points
et vous vous divisez chacun 20 points 6
points chacun d'abord parce que j'ai
fait pour pierre pierre notre technicien
avait t-il la bonne réponse notre
technicien obligeant les bonnes réponses
ne pas trop choquer alors il veut pas se
prononcer yahoo il ya encore 80 points à
aller chercher
c'est bien ça 80 points du groupe à
atteindre pour répondre de questions
allons nous avons un spécialiste de
l'autisme des troubles de l'autisme ici
qui est au bout du fil en fait c'est au
bout du skype faut avoir réinventé le
vocabulaire pour pour bien faire là oui
oui exactement
alors écoutez il s'agit de l'heure en
moutons qui est titulaire de la chaire
de recherche en neurosciences cognitives
fondamentale et appliquée du spectre
autistique à l'université de montréal
bonjour professeur bonjour alors écoutez
est ce qu'on peut parler de l'éléphant
qui est sûr cliquez dans la pièce c'est
bien de parler de l'autisme
c'est fondamentalement important de
mieux comprendre les problèmes qui sont
associés à l'autisme
mais quand les médias tous les médias on
parle au mois d'avril peut être que des
débordements peut-être qu'il ya des
choses qu'on exagère est ce que vous
aimeriez faire des mises au point
vous venez d'en donner une excellente
illustration en vous accordant sur un
chiffre de 1 sur 63 qui est celui qui
prévaut aux états unis mais vous savez
quand on ne connaît pas quelque chose
avec précision ça pas grand sens de
donner des décimales
la précision de ce chiffre est déjà
suspecte parce qu'actuellement il ya
tellement de flou dans la définition
même de l'autisme et il n'y a pas de ce
qu'on appelle de gaulle standard c'est à
dire que dans des situations frontières
on peut pas être sûr que l'on a tort ou
raison de mettre un diagnostic d'autisme
dans ces cas là ce qu'on fait c'est un
consensus entre chercheurs aux
cliniciens
mais un consensus ça peut juste être
tout le monde qu'ils se trompent en même
temps nous ça peut être un effet de mode
donc ce chiffre est généralement revu à
la baisse et je vous dirai par exemple
si on compare les chiffres qui prévalent
aux états unis et ceux qui prévalent en
grande bretagne vous avez une différence
à peu près de 1 à 3 vos coûts de 1 à 2
on pense qu'il ya moins de 1 de 8 % donc
trois fois moins d'autisme vraiment
prototypique qui correspondent à la
description classique de l'autisme
quand on diminue la rigueur de cette
description là on augmente
progressivement la prévalence mais sans
jamais savoir exactement où s'arrêter
donc ce chiffre doit sur 63 et selon
l'avis de la plupart des professionnels
excessif
très bien autre chiffre qui pourrait
sembler suspect vous allez me dire si
c'est le cas ou non je lisais cette
semaine que autrefois il ya quelques
années peut-être trente ans on parlait
de 1 cas sur 2500 c'était un article qui
vous suggérait que lee avait de plus en
plus de cas ou qu'on diagnostique est de
plus en plus de cas au point où on
parlait presque d'une épidémie quand on
parle d'un on part de 1 sur 2500 et
qu'on arrive à un sur 66 ans et l'agencé
canadienne de la santé je pense qu'à
publier un rapport cette semaine qui est
arrivé avec ce chiffre là alors est ce
qui diminuait ce qu'il y a on reconnaît
plus les cas typique
alors on tend à donner de plus en plus
souvent le diagnostic d'autisme dans des
situations de plus en plus variés et
dans des situations qui sont de plus en
plus éloignés de la description initial
mais encore une fois il s'agit d'un
effet beaucoup plus de sociologie
science dont les causes sont
innombrables mais les plus faciles à
cerner son je dirais la très grande
popularité de nautisme qui fait que
l'autisme bénéficie à la fois d'un
niveau de lobbying d'un niveau de
service beaucoup plus important que
beaucoup d'autres conditions
c'est comme ça ce qui veut dire que pour
des parents qui ont un enfant qui
présente un tableau mal cerné ou pour
des enseignants par exemple qu'ils ont
dans leur classe un enfant avec un
tableau mal cernés et des problèmes de
socialisation la tentation est grande de
lui trouver une parenté avec l'autisme
le drame est que la façon dont sont
exprimés actuellement les critères
diagnostiques permet une très grande
latitude aux cliniciens donc
actuellement la catégorie otis est en
train de manger les autres catégories
pédopsychiatrique et 7 c'est doublement
dommageable parce que on doit être
capable d'améliorer la qualité des
services aux autistes sans tricher sur
le nombre mais aussi autant les autistes
et légendes groupe et d'autres
considèrent que quand on est autiste
c'est un grand bien d'avoir son
diagnostic
autant quand on l'est pas c'est tout à
fait dramatique de d'essayer de
ressembler ou de se reconnaître dans
quelqu'un qui n'a aucun rapport avec
vous et actuellement il ya un très grand
nombre d'enfants avec des hyper activité
grave avec des tours est grave avec des
troubles d'apprentissage avec toutes
sortes de particularités de
socialisation qui nous sont adressés
avec véritablement l'espoir qu'on les
trouve autiste mais bien à marie mais
oui ma question qu est ce qu un autiste
alors exactement pour vraiment le cerner
à qui est un autiste qui ne l'est pas
bon alors le exactement et
problématiques sont que si vous prenez
mettons les uns sur 63 qu'ils ont avec
définies aux états unis on va prendre
l'exemple des etats-unis 1
c'est vraiment un nombre tout à fait
important à l'intérieur mais ton 200
enfants défini selon ces critères là
vous allez en avoir une pub mettront une
vingtaine une trentaine qui sont
autistes pour tout le monde sur la table
tout le monde va reconnaître
abbassi l'autisme existe c'est ça donc
vous allez avoir des enfants qui
présentent un tableau extrêmement
caractéristiques je sais pas si on a le
temps là de le définir parce qu'en fait
tout le monde le connaît il ya des
aspects de socialisation atypique des
aspects de communication atypique et de
répétition des intérêts ni de
restriction des intérêts mais la forme
que cela prend peut être plus ou moins
spécifique sur ces 100 enfin vous allez
en avoir une vingtaine d'autres qui ont
un aspect de restriction des intérêts
mais qui n'ont pas eu de retard de
langage et qui ont des limites de
socialisation des particularités de
socialisation les anciens qu'on appelait
des syndrome d'asperger air dont et puis
l'autre ça les autres 50 qui restent ils
vont avoir certains aspects de ces
tableaux là mais pas tous ou alors ils
vont les avoir mais en moins est
actuellement la situation diagnostic de
ces patients qui sont sur le bord du
spectre est extrêmement problématique
parce que on n'a pas de critères autres
que le consensus ce qui est une une
équipe de vérité scientifique en fait
assez faible pour dire que ces gens sont
autistes et c'est aussi un problème
subjectif pour ces personnes parce
qu'elles ne savent pas à qui finalement
elle ressemble quelqu'un qui est sur le
bord du spectre
si vous lui dites bas utilisés pour vous
comprendre la grille de lecture d'un
autiste pull et standard il va comme ça
il va pas se reconnaître ou ce
partiellement mais en même temps si vous
lui dites pas finalement vous faites
partie de la majorité des gens vous êtes
un héros d'ipic y va parce que mettre
non plus donc je vous dirais qu'il en va
de l'autisme comme des autochtones c'est
la catégorie des métis qui souffrent le
plus et bien la loma oui j'aurais une
question il ya toujours un terme quand
on parle d' autisme ki moon qui attire
mon attention
ça dit on l'appelle le trouble du
spectre de l'autisme et ça ça nous
ferait faire un problème quand on parle
de troubles on parle de problèmes
et puis souvent on parle de ses enfants
autistes comme des enfants problème
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ça beaucoup
de mal bien entendu je fais beaucoup
d'efforts pour que le mot troubles
soient ôtés de toutes les institutions
qui l autisme ça ne veut pas dire que
dans certains cas l'avis de certains
autistes un véritable cauchemar pour eux
et parfois pour les gens qui l'entourent
ça veut dire que l'autisme est beaucoup
plus large que les gens dont la vie est
difficile ou qui rendent la vie
difficile à d'autres personnes
donc on peut très bien être un autiste
heureux bien portant et être quand même
extrêmement différents des gens qui
entourent
donc c'est vraiment à point je suis très
content que vous posez la question ça
prouve que ces idées là on confond leur
chemin l'autize peut être un trouble
mais il ne croit site pas avec un
trouble jeunes question en fait la
définition de l'autisme et ça ça vient
dans un bouquin qu'on appelle le dcm
quelque chose je sais pas pour quel
volume en hiver c'est le 6 le set
j'aime beaucoup lire lequel vous dites
donc un truc matin mais pourquoi ce
qu'ils ont mais tous ces jeunes là avec
différents problèmes
on essaie de les délais j'encadrais dans
l'autisme dans les troubles de
d'optimisme sur la je disais des bêtises
sur la base la démarche de catégoriser
des gens qui présentent une certaine
différence parce les connaissances
qu'ils avancent c'est en même temps une
reconnaissance de cette différence ça
aussi je prendrai une analogie au le
fait de pouvoir dire que des gens ont
une orientation sexuelle alternative
peut être peut avoir aussi bien des
aspects discriminatoires que des aspects
valorisant et de reconnaissance pour
tous ces gens il en est de l'autisme la
même chose le fait
mais peut être utilisé au pire des
femmes ou aux meilleurs des fins 20 la
quasi-totalité des autistes veulent être
reconnus comme tels parce que ça leur
donne et ça donne une légitimité à leurs
différences bien au delà du trouble
hockey dont il existe sous un mode
différent sans être forcément un
problème donc le ds le gros problème
avec le dsm c'est que c'est pas l'objet
lui même c'est que on en sort à nouveau
tous les 15 ans il est souvent en retard
sur les connaissances décalé sur les
connaissances mais surtout il va
déterminer des pratiques plus nette et
plus tranché que ce que la connaissance
est effectivement nous nous apprend sur
l'autisme
sans parler de choses complexes le dsm
fait ce qu'on appelle des diagnostics
catégorielles convoleraient ou on ne
l'est pas mais en même temps ils vous
parlent de spectre autistique ce qui par
définition est un diagnostic
dimensionnelle c'est à dire qu'on les
plus ou moins donc vous voyez déjà là
comme un problème quelque part
alors le dsm quand il a des
contradictions il s'embarrasse pas il
met toutes ensembles plissés aux
cliniciens se débrouiller professeur il
ya une autre vérité peut-être qu'il va
falloir démolir ou déconstruire vous de
choisir
c'est au sujet des femmes on dit souvent
que ce sont les garçons qui sont plus
sujets à des problèmes d'autisme et que
les filles c'est plus en retrait j'ai
même vu des chiffres le palu cité je
veux pas faire peur à personne mais ce
serait beaucoup plus important chez les
garçons que chez les filles
qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui de sa
de cette vérité là c'est là il ya une
petite révolution qui est tout à fait
intéressante mais qui comme d'habitude
doit être clarifiée pour pas donné lieu
à des graves incompréhension on a décrit
une première forme il se trouve
le hasard fait qu'on l'a décrite chez
les garçons donc on a caractérisé des
signes chez un groupe de gens qui
étaient en majeure partie des garçons et
on a donc défini ce qu'on appelle à ces
extras sio on a dit qu'il y avait quatre
autiste pour une garçon pour une petite
fille
neotys garçons et filles qui se présente
de la même manière et puis après on
s'est rendu compte quelques dizaines
d'années plus tard que quand on prenait
des gens d'intelligence normale ou
d'intelligence élevé on avait beaucoup
beaucoup plus de garçons que de filles
s'étaient pas 4 pour 1 mais 7 et 8 ou 10
pourra donc on s'est dit plus on monte
en intelligence plus la forme autistique
coïncide avec le fait d'être un garçon
les gens ont vécu là dessus pendant 20
ans à peu près et puis il ya eu une idée
totalement révolutionnaire qui est sorti
il ya quelques années ce qui mais
attention si plus on monte en
intelligence moins il ya de fait c'est
peut-être que plus on vend tant
d'intelligence plus les filles autistes
présente une forme d'autisme qui est
yves stock de la forme masculine qui
avait permis d'identifier l'autisme du
bien donc c'est un sujet de travail
fantastique novateur n'y en a pas
toujours autant que sa conscience
sauf via un dark side ah ça oui parce
que on pourrait dire qu'il ya d'esprit à
même de circularité mettons qu'on
reconnaisse pas les autistes filles
n'ont pas d'accord ça veut dire qu'il a
peut-être plus mais si on les reconnaît
pas on est un peu dans le trouble pour
les compter si vous n'avez pas de
critères à ce moment là c'est le free
for all
toutes les femmes quand quelque chose de
spécial et puis qui sont mal catégoriser
par la psychiatrie on va parler par
exemple ce qu'on appelle les troubles de
personnalité ont la tentation d'être
reconnu comme autiste ce qui peut être
tout à fait vrai et salvateur dans un
certain nombre de cas mais qui peut être
tout à fait fou dans un homme autres
nombre de cas donc vous voyez qu
exactement où je disais pour les enfants
tout à l'heure on a le choix entre un
problème de sous diagnostic qui est
dramatique mais un problème de
surdiagnostic possible qui est tout
aussi problématique et on manque de
critères
parce que ces critères là je vous dirais
c'est la communauté scientifique et 7
les établis mais n'a pas d'autre moyen
que le consensus
donc nous
on a lancé une corde francophones qui a
eu beaucoup de succès on a maintenant
plus plus de 400 personnes qui se sont
inscrites qui sont des personnes qui
sont auto diagnostic et et on va voir
quelle est la valeur de l'autodiagnostic
par rapport aux diagnostics par la
communauté scientifique et donc on
travaille là dessus on travaille donc à
l'établissement de critères d'autisme
féminin on n'est pas les seuls à faire
ça de façon de donner une sorte de ligne
de partage
parce que moi je reçois de façon très
régulière des personnes qui n'ont à peu
près rien avoir à mon sens simplement
parce que je suis expert au sens où j'en
ai vu quelques milliers qui me
paraissent extrêmement éloignée de
l'autisme et qui elles se reconnaissent
dans des descriptions d'autisme et mon
travail est d'essayer de trouver des
lignes de partage pour ces personnes
mais pour les professionnels et pour la
science en général et professeurs on a
une dernière question qui vient de
paloma vous parliez tout à l'heure
professeur de la popularité entre
guillemets de l'autisme du du lobbying
qui est de plus en plus pressants qu'est
ce que vous pensez de la notion de neuro
diversité qui est amenée par certains
lobbies de l'autisme
je suis très impliquée dans le mouvement
de l'université et je crois que le
groupe de montréal fait partie qui rêve
était de devenir des gros joueurs un
petit peu de ce groupe là de façon
diverse à chacun ses positions mais
c'est pour être simple et rapide c'est
quelque chose que je cautionne c'est
quelque chose auquel je crois énormément
c'est quelque chose qui comme n'importe
quel mouvement doit voir des excès et à
lui dire quelques bêtises mais ça me
semble un grand progrès je crois très
profondément à l'idée quand j'essaie de
résumer ça d'une humanité qui n'auraient
pas sans entre donc dans lequel on se
sortent définitivement des anglo saxon
protestant riches au milieu et puis des
autochtones homosexuels
otis à la pergola
non et puis et puis évidemment les
femmes est en quelque part entre les
deux dans une couronne
donc je trouve cette un immense progrès
de données de droit un statut identique
en terme de droit à toutes les personnes
quel que soit leur niveau de variétés
indépendamment du fait que leur vie soit
plus ou moins facile qui soit plus ou
moins excentrée par rapport à ce qui
serait la moyenne la plus fréquente des
humains vous voyez qu'on soit très
nuancée dans ces choses là et c'est
souvent ce qui est appelé sous le terme
de neuro diversité merci beaucoup pour
cette diversité de points de vue c'était
fantastique de voir l'édition regard des
règlements des comptes en instruction et
qu'on est on comprend mieux et on sait
qu'il ya des limites à notre
compréhension
en tout cas c'est un grand plaisir
alors c'était le professeur laurent
motton titulaire de la chaire de
recherche en neuroscience cognitive
fondamentale et appliquée du spectre
autistique à l'université de montréal
mieux connu sous le nom de ubm dans son
propre pays il est tellement intéressant
ramifications dans sa façon de penser de
façon de voir si c'est pour toute la
société qui nous interpelle non les
hommes les femmes les homosexuels les
autochtones
vous êtres humains koala l'ensemble des
êtres humains
bah on se sent plus rassuré d'être
anormal je pensais surtout data oui
petit côté un peu fou fou oui c'est je
pense qu'on est prêt pour notre toit
deuxième manar moment de folie à
l'émission pour notre jeu de la grosse
boule deuxième tour je vous rappelle lé
score 10 10 et 20 c'est très chaud on va
parler de notre sujet favori de monsieur
trempe donald de son prénom qui a subi
plus tôt cet hiver il avait on pensait
qu'il avait des problèmes d'entre
cognitif
il avait il a subi un test test de
montréal le test moka pour évaluer son
déficit cognitif apparent dont certains
et d
certaines viennent moi je fais que lire
ce qui est écrit un certain que j'ai je
veux pas aller veux pas faire un prénom
certains scientifiques se lancer
associatif et on aurait des pétés de la
scientifique
voilà alors dites moi voici la question
c'est très sérieux
on rit pas sur une note de 30 quel était
le score de trompe et qu'il a obtenu
comme ça aux tests cognitifs canadien
inventé à montréal par le chercheur
ici à montréal trente et un le plus des
vélos me le meilleur là à l'école
c'était 20 sur 20 mois j'avais toujours
20 sur 20 c'est à 5 c'est que tu es
malade à la note maximale de tenues
combien 6,6 moyon dont je suis sûr que
vingt sept 27 27 sur 30 moi j'allais
dire 25 25 sur 30 qui dit mieux
m et 1,28 elle voit le bout scoop sapait
la confiance au test event
le pire c'est moi je suis dans le coin
et d'ailleurs pour lui afin qu'il paie
c'est parfait je le garde
cissé ben faut pas donner votre opinion
quand même alors voici d'opinion je
sache et l'uda les élus score reflète
les opinions non non pas du tout du tout
avant voici la bonne réponse qui était
le plus proche de 30
les 28 28
alors ses 30 points pour madame se
présente
il a eu 30 sur 30 le score maximum je
suis sûr que son médecin qui aujourd'hui
est appelé à de plus grandes fonctions
lui a glissé les questions du test avant
à vous voyez donc c'est moi qui ai gagné
non parce qu'on est l'une des nouvelles
ok il y avait très bien fait
on parle plus de problèmes cognitifs
valoir des troubles mais vous êtes sûr
que c'était pas du feq news goûter par
sa part comme il fallait un moment de
plaisir parce qu'on aime se retrouver
ensemble chaque semaine et c c'est vrai
la jument dream team
écoutez les délais pour faire tester son
enfant il en a parlé quand on a vraiment
un problème son enfant il a vraiment un
problème d'autisme oui il ya des
problèmes pour obtenir des services
montrent onecca tellement personnes qui
disent oui mon enfant a un problème
peut-être mais c'est pas un problème
beaucoup de demandes beaucoup de
demandes pour des services et peu de
services disponibles au canada on parle
d'une crise des services de l'autisme je
sais pas si vous vous pouvez en
témoigner
c'est vrai à part d'être vrai un fait ya
les forces dans les écoles ici au moins
ce que je comprends de ce que j'ai je
vivais à tous les jours tout quand on en
parle avec avec la professionnelle
l'histoire c'est que les les les gens
qui sont en face des élèves et son port
est très bien si s'outiller pour définir
alors c'est une réflexe très facile
d'émettre à ya un trouble autistique rue
là ça se passe alors les professionnels
qui vont déterminer si c'est vraiment un
trouble il se trouve avec une chose
normalement ça devrait être une
quinzaine des tests annuels
il se trouve avec un soixantaine 70
passant à a fait passer des tests pour
voir si c'est vraiment comme ça parce
que une fois qu'ils aient signalé
il faut pref il faut
c'est compliqué bien plus il n'y a pas
beaucoup de services dans l'est au moins
dans une des comédiennes scolaire s'est
pas suicidé comme si les provinces où
chaque chaque province un programme
différent dead de soutien ou services ma
femme par exemple ils travaillent 24 4
écoles différentes
il ya un journée par école puis beaucoup
de temps pour faire c'est ça c'est ça
il ya comme un 10 ans les parents et
dijon mais on n'a pas de service mais la
miss les professionnels il doit partager
l'habitation pour faire le traitement
avec d'autres professionnels sais c'est
pas facile non plus la façon dont eux et
ils ont initié pour pouvoir face au
travail
j'aimerais vous proposer à tous une
image je pense qu'on va reconnaître ici
un livre qui est disponible maintenant
sur marché ici au québec
un an exactement qui est paru il ya un
an l'autisme expliquer ou non autistes
qui permet aux parents non seulement de
repérer les signes parce qu'il sait non
spécialistes mais on vous ai dit si on
vous donne des trucs plus que des trucs
qu'on vous donne des recettes pas des
recettes des endroits des façons de
communiquer ministre était pour
communiquer avec votre enfant pour qu'il
soit plus plus détendu vous même vous
soyez plus détendu d'établir cette
communication là c'est ce qui est plus
difficile
vous trouvez mais vous avez des outils
pour le faire des stratégies pour le
faire l'enfant se sauvent louis petit
peu il sent qu'il peut sortir il peut
s'aventurer
alors je vous propose est d'aller vers
une entrevue vous allez tout sera la
reconnaître kim thuy ça vous dit quelque
chose
je pensais être justement parce que j'ai
vu un reportage à la télévision
récemment où on la voyait avec son
garçon est justement les stratégies
qu'elle avait développée pour mieux le
comprendre qui est aussi envoyé un
reportage on voit on voit comment tisser
un peu plus assaisonner ils voient que
leurs épaules de la bonne couleur dont
il a manqué un peu de sauce d'ajouter un
peu de sauce alors qu'avant il y aurait
juste pour manger aussi non refuser le
plat
on n'aurait pas su pourquoi maintenant
ici que s'ils me le demande je vais
comprendre alors qu'avant il sait pas
qui pouvait me demander c'est fou ça a
l'air tellement faim comme ça mais ça
enlève de la wii l'inconnue divin
pourquoi il veut pas manger
selon qin celui-ci son fils arrive
aujourd'hui à se comprendre et se faire
comprendre
c'est beaucoup grâce au travail de deux
québécoises spécialiste de l'autisme
sélectionné je vois brigitte harrison
lycées charles se sont donné pour
mission d'expliquer l'autisme ou non
autistes faire comprendre à tous comment
fonctionne le cerveau d'une personne
atteint de ce trouble
neurodéveloppemental il ya encore
beaucoup de méconnaissance de l'autisme
comme tel il ya encore beaucoup de
mythes qui circulent la personne autiste
a pas le même et pas à pas la même paire
de lunettes à l'intérieur car non mathis
et son faut que les gens l'appellent
faut qu'il change d'attitude au tour
pour être capable d'aider la personne à
se développer
pour brigitte harrison y est tellement
émotif
l'objectif est de donner une voix aux
autistes la journée où les autres
suisses vont être entendus les noms
notice va avoir pas mal de problèmes
avec les autistes
une fois qu'on me comprend le cerveau de
d'un autiste mais on peut voir encore
une fois la mer comprend aussi que le
cerveau de son fils fonctionne de façon
beaucoup plus statique comme un
enchaînement de diapositives
on dit souvent que les eti sont rigides
mais c'est son corrigé de sont statiques
parce qu'ils prennent des images et non
pas en film non poreux et passe même
vraiment et pas demain qui a pris une
image la tangerine est à droite de la
passe mais là si je déplace et que des à
tanger rennais et si le juge yves
allemande en allemand la tangerine ça
prend du temps parce qu'il doit
reprendre une autre photo peut dire ou
es à tanger ryct mais il faut qu'ils
décollent
ah oui la passe et ça c'est une tasse ce
site de tangerine je vais prendre la
tangerine puis je vais donner à ma main
il ya beaucoup d'étapes à faire non si
on veut enlever cet état statique on lui
montre un divan maman bouge à tanger
réunion du lendemain il a vu il a
enregistré puis ça finit là alors mais
avec avec le développement avec le
travail qu'on fait à l'intérieur on n'a
même plus besoin de lui montrer ici que
la tangerine des fois et bouge alors mes
blagues savons aujourd'hui je peux
travailler en même temps avec balmont à
côté est tellement calme est tellement
bien et heureux
le but d'un parent c'est quoi c'est
d'abord son enfant heureux alors là
c'est un raccourci du dadou d'actes
tellement intéressant vraiment mais
c'est ça un moment donné on voyait dans
un autre reportage que j'ai vu on voit
comme si on était dans le cerveau des
gens alors on voit comment quelqu'un dit
normal enfin rang je me rangerai ne s'y
pique ouais j'aime bien ce terme
comment ils voient le monde et comment
un autiste voit le monde tellement
intéressant parce qu'après quand je
rencontre mon voisin j'ai l'impression
de mieux le comprendre vraiment ça fait
toute la différence
ouais moi j'ai appris cette semaine je
comprends si je veux parler à un enfant
qui est autiste je comprends maintenant
il faut que je prenne mon temps
oui je bouge ou à tout autour de lui
j'arrive pas comment était ajournée
comment tu vas faut pas faire ça par
n'ont pas dit non non comment était
ajournée
[Rires]
oui c'est quelqu'un qui que j'ai connue
par sa mère sa mère est une artiste
visuel et puis lucas c'est un enfant que
j'ai connu à travers sa mère puis au
début je ne comprenais pas sa façon
d'agir mais finalement on a qu'on a fait
une belle entrevue je l'interviewais
j'ai réussi à convaincre l'ucad a
participé avec moi plus parler des
sceaux nautisme
quelle coïncidence par la magie du web
votre votre entrevue sur la page de
tam-tam cette semaine ainsi que trois
autres entrevue ou article vous avez
signé depuis un an et demi que vous êtes
avec eux vous avez je me fais j'ai fait
du repérage cette semaine cet avis qui
le plus sur l'a7 quelques mois merci de
me l'a dit je ne savais pas
donc tout le monde peut suivre les
articles que vous avez écrit au fil des
derniers mois sur la page web de tam-tam
canada donc en fait vous avez parlé à un
enfant qui est capable de s'exécuter ma
fille lucca
j'ai beaucoup de travail avec sa mère et
avec des intervenants pour pouvoir
parler puis exprimer marie-claude vous
exprimer pas beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est
parce que j'ai beaucoup de choses je
vois qu'il ya des gens qui connaît très
bien le sujet je laisse parler
j'apprends dans tout ça d'accord vous
avez pas de problème à différer donc la
vidéo numéro 4 non mais j'avais facilité
des fusées positif et vous allez lire ce
que je voyage à l'antenne car l'iss
ottomane s'adresse agents à justin
trudeau lors de l'assemblée publique du
premier ministre le 9 janvier en fait on
reviendra à l'eau à sackville en
nouvelle écosse et elle lui parle de son
fils qui à mon appel je pense nous
vivons un cauchemar
oui et puis ça c'est une histoire qui a
fait le tour du canada anglais surtout
et la joie et je ne peux pas le serrer
dans mes bras je ne peux pas le toucher
il ya une faute de frappe là c'est moi
je l'écoutais crier à l'étagé faire des
trous dans les murs toute la journée
il ya encore des
c'est très descriptif mes mains mes bras
sont couverts des granites
d'égratignures de morsures cas l'homme a
donné un coup de poing sur le visage je
pense
il a développé une phobie des toilettes
durant son séjour à l'hôpital alors
maintenant nous passons des heures
chaque jour à nettoyer d escrime ans
alors elle a accordé des entrevues à ces
missi au réseau privé également en
anglais et puis c'est une histoire qui a
fait le tour du canada et qui illustre
les problèmes de service aux parents qui
ont besoin des aides pour pour pressées
de faire quelque chose avec leurs
enfants
oui c'est des enfants qui doivent être
encadrés toute la journée jour et nuit
en fait certains d'entre eux la cdca
exact de service' absence de service de
soulages de soulagement pour le parent
qui est qui est une victime aussi
comment on s'occupe des parents qui sont
âgés des fois qu'ils sont malades
s'il pleut quand on s'occupe d'enfants
qui vieillissent avec ça on aura le don
otis toute sa vie moi je pensais que ça
pouvait soigner
on peut en fait on on peut bien vivre
si on a les services pis si les niveaux
n'est pas de trop oui donc
[Musique]
je voulais je voulais vous amener
maintenant vers un sujet qui connexes
qui s'est produit dans l'actualité cette
semaine on va vers ça en deux ou trois
bons d'accord un peu comme au zoo
n'était que je vous accorde tous une
note alors on ça commence par un jeu de
la grosse boule c'est notre tension
autiste est terminée on va lire d'autres
troupes
d'accord ils sont nombreux alors les
incapacités liées aux troubles
d'apprentissage avec 2,3 pour cent de la
population canadienne voilà une
statistique il faudra peut-être remettre
en doute après avoir entendu le
professeur votre nom maintenant en tout
cas je vous la livre
ça vient de statistique canada alors ils
peuvent pas dire que des bêtises
voici quel est le pourcentage en ce
moment d aide aux canadiens qu'ils
disent éprouver un de ces trois types
d'incapacité les plus répandus
ce n'est pas des problèmes le cerveau
neurologique non on parle de douleurs de
problèmes de mobilité ou de flexibilité
m'avait vu cette semaine je j'avais des
problèmes durant quatre jours je me
promenais pratiquement comme sur des
béquilles je me faisais ce que je
travaille trop fort moi c'est parce que
j'ai donné un coup de pied à mon chien
danser je suis fier c'est le nerf
sciatique sur tours et de vieux
croulants
moi je continue à essayer de faire
aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale de l'exercice
simon fait courir ensuite sur dabul
alors ça vaut pour 50 points c'est la
troisième qu'elle ce stage
oui je me suis mis d'une question alors
2e qu'un troisième tour bon pour 50
points quel est le pourcentage en semant
des adultes qui ont des problèmes de
flexibilité de douleurs de mobilité 100%
sur 100 % que les pourcentages en ce
moment même sur ce tas du droit le 18 à
98,2 euros à 68 ans et vous voulez
inquiet bas de 18 au moins d'adultes de
dire et 45% 45% et bien gérée 76 pierre
de techniciens 55%
ici en studio peut-être 55% tandis si je
regarde la moyenne vous avez tous -
quelque part sauf moi ouais ok j'en
connais ressources mondiales pour 104 76
mais qui est ce qui est plus proche de
la bonne réponse 6,75 11% alors paloma
félicitations vous avez 90 % exigés pour
sa 20 % 20 %
comment ça c'est tous les jours on
rencontre du monde qui nous disait
j'imagine qu'on parle et on parle de
problèmes sérieux qu'un belge qui vous
empêche d'aller au travail la question
ouais alors d'y penser à des cas vous
écrivez ou peuvent pas vous présenter
aux tarés jean le problème de la
précédente enquête
voilà c'est rassurant moi j'étais au
travail toute la semaine de juillet
alors écoutez c'est ça alors écoutez
c'est quand même de sérieux là ça s'est
passé ça concernait warm heart entendu
parler de ça qu'est ce qu'a fait warm
heart ses employés il y avait un
handicap intellectuel parce qu'ils
pouvaient pu avoir son programme qui est
des ces gens-là ça c'était gris g
il a fait volte-face c'est un pagne kita
c'est un gouvernement resserré le
financement ces bois n'a plus mis en
place ce projet qui a décidé d'y mettre
fin et ça peut être une bonne idée
ils ont fait ça au moment où ce n'est
pas au moment où on parlait de l'autisme
et puis pub l'exercice exercice fallait
faire pendant le mois de l'autisme mais
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que c'était
le mois de mai mois de l'autisme
journées internationales de l'autiste
qui a chez walmart c'était un grain
publicité pour le pôle pour le problème
de l'autisme nommé
du côté problème de l'autisme et spears
idée la marque
tout le monde parle de goldman
maintenait mouais tout le monde parle de
temps à leur écoute et on accélère la
cadence et non parce que juno minutes
amusant oui ça avec son allons forer en
bobine comme dans un bon vieux temps
comédien qui a un fils comme timing puis
là on est dans poc je sais pas mais bon
on voudrait qu'on passe et qui n'a parlé
de religion la médecine dans les voûtes
ont paru des valeurs humaines
c'était un bon moment pour se retrouver
en famille puis de faire ça à part que
je trouve que c'est le times et le plus
épouvantable
moi je gagne très bien ma vie vraiment
très bien ma vie pourtant la peur que
j'ai ce qu'est ce qui va arriver à mon
fils non verbal quand je serai mort la
deuxième chose c'est pourra-t-il se
réaliser pourra-t-il avoir une estime de
soi
aura-t-il des amis aura-t-il une vie en
dehors de la maison
en dehors de tillemont face à 16 ans il
coûte encore du baby einstein monfils
qui promet il pourrait même pas
travailler chez walmart
donc quand je vois ça mais je vieillis
une angoisse
j'ai besoin de franchir les parents qui
ont 65 ans et de 35 me qu'est ce qu'ils
font qu'est ce qu'ils font si une
société on n'est pas capable de
s'occuper de nos vieux d'éduquer nos
enfants puis de s'occuper des laissés
pour compte
choisir le bon je dois garder le bateau
loin au bout puis comme et profits l'ont
fait et puis je peux communiste le mélo
un citoyen corporatif quand même moi je
vais aller acheter ou déjà en tout cas
donc je charles lafortune animateur très
bien que du canapé au québec qui
l'animateur de voice en anglais on
appellerait ça vous est ce que je pense
et la foi ne sais pas qui était
l'animateur de la boue non plus je
regarde pas la compétition droit à
l'écouté
voici notre question entame on a posé ça
sur facebook cette semaine au sujet de
warm heart quelle belle combinaison il
ya deux semaines en 7è facebook ont
attaqué quand on s'en prend à avoir
marre pas nous mais les l'actualité
alors voici la question
moi je vois bien la partie importante de
la question et lui ne disparaît la
partie importante de la question est
faudrait-il rendre obligatoire ce genre
de programme dans toutes les grandes
entreprises ces programmes pour les
personnes qui auraient aidé à intégrer
les personnes et fait un tour de table
amri 100% oui ça s'applique pas
je pense au niveau des entreprises
fédérales il faut avoir un programme
d'intégration des personnes avec
handicap mais pas au niveau des petites
entreprises privées ou des grandes
entreprises privées parlement ici à
radio canada ont un programme
d'intégration des personnes avec des
handicaps d'handicap en fait il y à un
comité qui a été créé l'année dernière
pour ouvrir à fait pour créer des quotas
parce que ça commence toujours par des
quotas mais aussi pour les travailleurs
qui ont un handicap à l'intérieur déjà
de la snel un drop de radio canada
puisse sensibiliser les autres implants
a employé jeudi employeur je vous le dis
employées et employés toujours les
paysans pays mène on y va oui on devrait
absolument 100% d'accent % d'accord on
fait le tour des bas parce que c'est la
seule façon on essaie de comprendre les
pourquoi on essaie d'aider des coûts des
catégories c on essaie de les aider
d'une certaine façon mais la meilleure
façon d'aider ces gens locks et femmes
il s'est intégré le reste du travail
mais s'ils sont pas autonomes au moins
qui puisse être c'est sentir
oui et nous valoriser aussi vous
imaginez l'effet que ça sur sur nous qui
nous disent on commet déjà euros typique
voilà mes de sentir que on a déjà pour
nous mais pour eux aussi apporter
quelque chose de grande importance
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
ici à radio-canada je vois souvent
la différence employés cep accompagner
un employé aveugle c'est ils font partie
d'une équipe en particulier d'avoir
envoyé je sais pas laquelle
mais je sais que il s'accompagne cette
personne-là à la cafétéria jeter un café
à la toilette parce que cette personne
je ne sais pas c'est quoi son travail
exactement mais évidemment elle a un
emploi à radio canada qu'il est capable
de réaliser
mais pour le déplacement à l'intérieur
de ces buildings l'homme il faut il lui
faut des leds donc et toujours
différence employés qui l'accompagné
désaccord employés qu'il faut partir de
son équipe
donc c'est très beau à voir et ça
sensibilise tout le monde autour c'est
surtout voir comment ils se déplacent
est problématique pour trouver la porte
et puis puis ça fait en sorte aussi qu'
on se sensibilisent fillon se dit bhl
c'est vrai que nous on a la vie facile
oui merci donc à l'équipe de rêve de
radio canada international à marivan
merci merci pour nous avoir fait vivre
cette émission enrichissante mais
d'importants jalons pris le terme le
typique mais en fait il y avait
quelqu'un qui m'appelait nilotique mais
c'est pas la magie névrotique ou
neurotoxique les deux convalescents
[Rires]